Hello everybody, this is Dr. Cotters. Again, step two is to take action on the triggers that you don't want this video unless you did step one
Okay, so step two is to start taking action on the triggers
that you
Started to assess yourself, you know, for what are some of these triggers that are
firing up your autoimmune reaction your symptoms your you know ill health what are some of these symptoms?
You have to pick a starting point, so I'm gonna give you most common starting points here
So it's gonna be different for everybody. Maybe you're way down the list here. We'll get to that
But you have to stick you have to pick a starting point
So your most common starting points to calm down inflammation are gonna be food
Why because you eat anyhow so we can get rid of like okay, we're not gonna we're gonna get rid of clean products
You know that have chemicals. We're gonna get rid of all these different things and that's the next step
So we're gonna clean up our environment
But you are consuming food on a daily basis you have to so you are consuming
potential inflammatory targets on a daily basis you're consuming
Potential time bombs every single day. So you have to look at those things
You know as that potential time bomb these are foods. What are you talking about if you have anybody's against them
They're time bombs and they're gonna cause fire so we have to look at these most common is gluten
dairy corn, egg, night chains, sugar, glutamate so we talked about those. We're gonna continue to talk about those
So where do you start with this? Well a good starting place with this is to look at these possible diets
You know going to gluten free going dairy free going to cross-reactive grains looking at cross-reactive lists
And I'll have those in this course one our gluten cross-reactive foods one our dairy cross-reactive foods
You might have gluten sensitivity and you stay enough a gluten
You would help a little bit, but now you're just not helped at all
Well, you're consuming a cross-reactive food meeting something that is cross-reactive with gluten like oats or something
That is is firing the equal amount to stuff. You're eating a gluten free diet meaning gluten things that are gluten-free
Substitutes that have a grade in there or a net in there that you are
Do you have you know fire red at a Syracx test with meaning that you have very high antibody?
Reactions too, so you know you're not quellied much as a fire. So you've got to figure out what's causing the fire
Night-chained issues lectin issues, so there's
Stages to the some people will just go out of gluten free diet and it calms everything down and they feel like
60% better and they feel like hey, I can live my life this way
I feel like I'm in a relative state of remission with my
Symptom patterns and and uncomfortable living this way some people have to go
You know deeper and deeper and deeper to really clean this all up before they can start adding things back
I touched on the last video about sodium intake and I'll have a video about this
But sodium don't overlook that, you know salt in our diet has been found with new studies out there that this can be a major
Reacted for autoimmune disorders of all different types
Patients with autoimmunity should consume potassium if eating salty food that has been shown for some people if they take a lot of potassium
When they're going to eat salty food it decreases that reaction some people understand don't react at all to salt so maybe that's not your issue
But some studies have shown that
1,000 to 3,000 milligrams of potassium by carbonate after salty meals just
Quells that whole reaction for them now that's a lot you typically have to get that in a powder form not in a capsule form
But you know just or just to really observe how much salt tolerance they they can handle and they can balance I touched on
Blood glucose balancing. This is a huge piece for people
And well, I don't have diabetes my doctor said I don't have diabetes. What is that fluctuation of glucose?
It's not necessarily diabetes can be low blood sugar to that hypoglycemia hyperglycemia
Bounds and causes all sorts of problems not to mention
insulin resistance and ultimately
Diabetic issues
but a huge piece to this can be just
Starting intermittent fasting that could be a huge piece to somebody so you're you're picking you're
You're starting place here
You know course glue to the dairy and food sensitivities are most common places to start
But another thing to think about is to do some intermittent fasting of some sort of what's called time restricted eating
Meaning that I'm gonna maybe just start eating within a shorter window usually I wake up at a breakfast at eight o'clock
And I have much on different things until lunch and I have lunch at noon and then I much on a bunch different things
And we have a big meal at five o'clock and I much on different things before I go to sleep
You're not giving you're gonna rest at all
Maybe it's just starting to cut that window down
I'm gonna start not eating anything till noon and I'm gonna stop eating till at seven o'clock
So I have a seven-hour window of eating and then
Gradually I might cut that down
And maybe I don't have to do this every day. Maybe I'm only gonna do this three days a week or two days a week
I got to cut my window down to six hours or five hours or four hours
I'm only gonna I get away till three o'clock to eat and then I'm gonna finish eating at six or not eat anything after six
I got a three-hour window two days a week. That's a type of fasting
Fasting can be good for us. Don't go on a three-day faster or seven day faster or something like that without starting with what I just said
But going on that time-restricted eating that cutting our window down doesn't have to be daily
It can be just several days a week like I said can be huge to give our got to rest and to calm down that
Inflammation in our gut and in our body. That can be a huge thing
But I like I said a lot of times the first place to start is the most common
So don't overlook what is the biggest possibility going out there and that's gluten and dairy
So look at those things first and how to cut those things down
Take your steps wisely make sure you don't bite off more than you can chew
Everybody's excited to get better right off the bat
But do this in pieces know this is a lifestyle. This is your whole life
This is gonna take time to do continue to study and continue to know that that's what your call it is
And you're doing this not just for yourself, but for your family and a whole bunch of other people anything that you
Can learn to share with other people. That's gonna be a blessing. All right. Thanks so much. No, I pray it for you. Bye bye